>>> THIS MORNING IS A MASSIV
CLEANUP BEGINNING  NEW ORLEANS
AFR A TORNADO HIT AND LEFT
TRAIL OF DTRUCTION IN SEVERAL
AREAS.
THIS STORM, YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT
HERE, IT FLIPPED CARS, IT TORE
THE ROOFS OFF OF SOME HOMES.
OTHERS WERE JUST COMPLETELY
RIPPED OFF OF THEIR FOUNDATIONS.
ONE PERSON THAT WE KNOW OF WAS
KILLED.
AND WHEN YOU SEE THESE STUNNING
IMAGES OF THE DAMAGE, THAT SEEMS
LIKE A MIRACLE.
CNN'S DEREK VAN DAM JOINING US
NOW FROM HARD HIT ST. BERNARD
PARISH.
TELL US WHAT YOU'RE SEEING NOW
THAT THE DAY HAS DAWNED.
>> Reporter: YEAH, BRIANNA, WE
HAVE GOT OUR FIRST LIGHT HERE,
JUST ADJACENT TO THE LOWER NINTH
WARD, EAST OF NEW ORLEANS.
AND WE'RE GETTING THAT FIRST
GLIMPSE OF DAYLIGHT AND GETTING
US AND REVEALING TO US AS WELL
AS THE RESIDENTS HERE THE TRUE
NATURE OF THE DEVASTATION LEFT
BEHIND BY THIS POWERFUL TORNADO
THAT STRUCK ABOUT 7:30 LOCAL
TIME LAST NIGHT.
LET'S TAKE YOU TO THE AIR, SHOW
YOU WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE FROM
ABOVE.
AND YOU TOO AT HOME CAN GET AN
IDEA OF HOW BAD IT WAS, WE
TALKED TO THE ST. BERNARD PARISH
PRESIDENT EARLIER THIS MORNING
AND HE TOLD CNN THAT WHEN YOU
GUYS SEE WHAT HAPPENED
OVERNIGHT, ONCE THAT DAYLIGHT
HITS THE DAMAGE SCENE, YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE THAT IT WAS TRULY A
MIRACLE.
HE WAS REFERENCING THE LIMITED
AMOUNT OF INJURIES THAT OCCURRED
WITH THIS POWERFUL TORNADO AND
UNFORTUNATELY THERE WAS A
CONFIRMED FATALITY, BUT THAT
NUMBER, OF COURSE, WITH THE
DEVASTATION WE'RE SEEING BEHIND
US COULD HAVE BEEN MUCH, MUCH
HIGHER.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU THE NATURE OF
A TORNADO, AS A METEOROLOGIST,
WE STUDIED THIS IN DEPTH, WE
UNDERSTAND DAMAGE PATTERNS AND
THIS IS VERY CHARACTERISTIC OF A
POWERFUL TORNADO.
IT IS INDISCRIMINATE IN WHAT IT
DESTROYS.
LOOK BEHIND ME HERE, YOU SEE
HOMES COMPLETELY UNTOUCHED,
VIRTUALLY UNTOUCHED BY THIS
TORNADO AND THEN YOU CAN SEE
CLEARLY WHAT IS A SCHOOL BUS
BEHIND ME THAT HAS BEEN FLIPPED.
IT HAS TRAVELED AT LEAST 100
YARDS FROM WHERE IT WAS PARKED
EARLIER THIS MORNING.
AND BEHIND MY RIGHT SHOULDER IS
A HOME WHERE THE ROOF HAS BEEN
COMPLETELY LIFTED OFF.
WE TALKED TO SOME RESIDENTS WHO
RODE OUT THIS TORNADO.
IT WAS A MOTHER AND FATHER OF
TWO CHILDREN THAT WERE 6 AND 8
YEARS OLD.
THEY LIVED JUST DOWN THE ROAD,
WITHIN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD IN ST.
BERNARD PARISH.
THEY TOLD ME THAT THEY COULD
ACTUALLY FEEL THE PRESSURE DROP
WITHIN THEIR EARS AS THE TORNADO
APPROACHED, THAT'S HOW POWERFUL
IT WAS